στης αγωγής ιγείας ου είναι ένα θέμανα έτσι αφιλεγόμενον πολύς κόσμος κάνει κριτική σε αυτόν
και χρειαζόταν να πάμε να εμείς ίδη να δούμε μαθήματα ως πεδαγωγικώ ινστητούτων τότε είχε
περάσει και η νομοθεσία που επιτρέπει στο δάσκαλον ιτη δασκάλα αν κάποιον παιδάκι αναφέρει ότιδήποτε
ιδίοι περίεργης συμπεριφορανήδαδασκάλα δικεαιούτε χωρίς χρονοτριβή να πάει απευθείας στην αστυνομία ιδασκάλαα χωρίς συνένες ιγωνιών
χωρίς να ενημερώσει διευθυντή και μου εσυνέβηκε δυστυχώς δεν θα το ξεχάσω ποτέ ήταν έναν
παιδάκι ν πιαγωγείου όπου εκεί που τους επεξηγούσε των κανώναν το εσορούχουν δεν αγγίζουμε δεν
αφήνουμε κανένα και λοιπά έναν αγουράκει είχε μπεικυρία οπαπούσ και ξεκίνηθε να λέει όπότε αμέσως
ακολουθήθηκε το πρωτόκολο ιδασκαλα ήταν εξαραεϊτική εμείς είχαμε να πλάσιο καριστεί και δεν δεν μπορούσαμε
να αντιδράσουμε ι η παρευρισκομετα αντριατεσράτομα που παραακολουθούσαμε να πότε από μόνος σε εντοπαιδάκι το
είδεμόνη της στο στήρι ξεφέραμε την ψυχολόγο και πήρε το δρόμο της ιστορία όπότε δυστυχώς
το είχα ζήσει αυτό και κατάλαβα από τότε πόσοψημαντικόν είναι τα παιδιά μας να έχουν
εκείνες στις γνώσει στις ικανότητες και τις δεξιότητες για να ναι αυτό όνομα ήταν κάτι
που δεν υπήρχε τα προηγομενα χρόνια α αυτόν και πολλές ιστορίες αποκριμώνατανεπρίβααβγήκαν χρόνια μετά όταν
το σύστημα κοινωνία βονα ο σε περισσόδερο και ξέρετε εκείνα τα παιδιάς αυτές τις τριφερές
οι λεγές μπορούμε να τα βοηθήσουμε τελικάνα μεγαλώσουμ πιος ωστά γιατί πολλές από τις ιστορίες
που ακούμε μετά κααπό άτομα αςσκουνβία είχαν δεχτεί η διηβία βεβαια όπότε μπρούμε να προλάβουμε
και γονότα και καταστάσες κάποιον περιστατικό το οποίο κάνετει να φη να μηχαει το να
πει κάνει ωνα μ παραιτούμεόσες υχρές σε παρατήθο καχαρι το λογόντας στους φίλς